on this planet today there are about 50
cities that are larger than 5 million
people I'm going to share with you the
story of one sad city a city of seven
million people but a city that's a
temporary mega city an ephemeral mega
city this is a city that is built for a
Hindu religious festival called the
Combe Mela which occurs every 12 years
in smaller additions every four years
and takes place at the confluence of the
Ganges and the Yamuna rivers in India
and for this festival about a hundred
million people congregate the reason so
many people congregate here is the
Hindus believe that during the festival
the cycle every 12 years if you bathe at
the confluence of these two great rivers
you are freed from rebirth it's a really
compelling idea you're liberated from
life as we know it and this is what
attracts these millions and an entire
mega city is built to house them seven
million people lived there for the fifty
five days and the other 100 million
visit these are images from the same
spot that we took over the ten weeks
that it takes for the city to emerge
after the monsoon as the waters of these
rivers begin to recede and the sand
banks exposed themselves it becomes the
terrain for the city and by the 15th of
January starting or 15th of October the
15th of January in these weeks and
entire city emerges a city that houses 7
million people what is fascinating is
this city actually has all the
characteristics of a real mega city a
grid is employed to lay the city out the
urban system is a grid
and every street on the city goes across
the river on a pontoon bridge incredibly
resilient because if there's an
unseasonal downpour or if the river
changes course the urban system stays
intact the city adjusts itself to this
terrain which can be volatile it also
replicates all forms of physical as well
as social infrastructure water supply
sewage electricity
there are thousands 400 CCTV cameras
that that are used for security by
entire station that is set up but also
social infrastructure like clinics
hospitals all sorts of community
services that make this function like
any real mega city would do ten thousand
five hundred sweepers are employed by
the city it has a government system a
mela Adhikari or the commissioner of the
festival that ensures that land is
allocated the systems for all of this
that the system of the city the mobility
all works efficiently you know it was
the cleanest and the most efficient
Indian city I've lived in and that's
what it looks like in comparison to
Manhattan 30 square kilometres
that's the scale of the city and this is
not an informal city or a pop-up city
this is a formal city this is a state
enterprise the government sets this up
in today's world of neoliberalism and
capitalism where the state has devolved
itself complete responsibility from
making and designing cities this is an
incredible case it's a deliberate
intentional City a formal City and it's
a city that sits on the ground very
likely it sits on the banks of these
rivers and it leaves very little mark
there are no foundations fabric is used
to build this entire city what's also
quite incredible
is that there are five materials that
are used to build this settlement for
seven million people
eight foot tall bamboo string or rope
nails a screw and a skinning material it
could be corrugated metal a fabric or
plastic and these materials come
together and aggregate it's like a kit
of parts and it's used all the way from
a small tent which might house five or
six people or a family to temples that
can house five hundred sometimes a
thousand people and this kit of parts
and this imagination of the city allows
it to be disassembled and so at the end
of the festival within a week the entire
city is disassembled these are again
images from the same spot and the
terrain is offered back to the river as
with the monsoon the water swells again
and it's this sort of imagination as a
kit of parts that allows this
disassembly and the reabsorption of all
this material so the electricity poles
go to little villages in the hinterland
the pontoon bridges are used in small
towns the material is all reabsorbed
fascinating it's amazing now you may
embrace these Hindu beliefs or not but
you know this is a stunning example and
it's worthy of reflection here human
beings spend an enormous amount of
energy and imagination knowing that the
city is going to reverse it's going to
be disassembled it's going to be
disappear it's the ephemeral mega city
and it has profound lessons to teach us
lessons about how to touch the ground
likely about reversibility about
disassembly rather amazing and you know
we are as humans obsessed with
permanence we resist change it's an
impulse that we all have and we resist
change in spite of the fact that change
is perhaps the only constant in our
lives everything has an expiry date
including spaceship earth our planet so
what can we learn from
these sorts of settlements burning man's
cost much smaller but reversible all the
thousands of markets for transaction
that appear around the globe in Asia
Latin America Africa this one in Mexico
where the parking lots are animated on
the weekends about 50,000 vendors but on
a temporal cycle the farmers market in
the Americas it's it's it's an amazing
phenomena creates new chemistry's
extends the margin of space that is
unused or not used optimally like
parking lots for example in my own city
of Mumbai where I practice as an
architect in a planner I see this in the
everyday landscape I call this the
kinetic city it twitches like a live
organism it's not static it changes
every day on sometimes predictable
cycles about six million people live in
these kinds of temporary settlements
like unfortunately like refugee camps
the slums of Mumbai the favelas of Latin
America here the temporary is becoming
the new permanent here urbanism is not
about grand vision it's about grand
adjustment on the street in Mumbai
during the Ganesh festival a
transformation a community Hall is
created for ten days Bollywood films are
shown thousands congregate for dinners
and celebration it's made out of paper
mache and plaster of Paris designed to
be disassembled and in ten days
overnight it disappears and the street
goes back to anonymity or our wonderful
open spaces we call them my dance and
it's used for this incredibly nuanced
and complicated fascinating Indian game
called cricket which I believe the
British invented and and in the evenings
a wedding wraps around the cricket pitch
notice the cricket pitches not touched
it's sacred ground
but here the club members and the
wedding party partake in tea through a
common kitchen and at midnight is
disassembled and the space offered back
to the city
here urbanism is an elastic condition
and so if we reflect about these
questions I mean I think many come to
mind but an important one is are we
really in our cities in our imagination
about urbanism making permanent
solutions for temporary problems are we
locking resources into paradigms that we
don't even know will be relevant in a
decade this becomes I think an
interesting question that arises from
this research I mean look at the
abandoned shopping malls in North
America suburban North America retail
retail experts have predicted that in
the next decade of the 2,000 miles that
exists today 50% will be abandoned
massive amount of material locked into I
mean capturing resources that will not
be relevant soon or the Olympic stadiums
around the globe cities build these
under great contestation with massive
resources but after the games go they
can't often get absorbed into the city
countries be pneumatic structures
deflatable we have the technology for
that that get gifted to smaller towns
around the world or in those countries
or move are stored and moved for the
next Olympics a massive use of
inefficient use of resources like the
circus I mean we could imagine it like
the circus this wonderful institution
that used to camp in cities set up this
lovely kind of visual dialogue with the
static city and and within it the
amazement children of different ethnic
groups become suddenly aware of each
other people of color become aware of
others income groups and cultures and
ethnicities all come together around the
amazement of the ring with animals and
performers new chemistry's are created
people become aware of things and this
moves on to the
town on nature the fluxes of nature
climate change how do we deal with this
can we won't be more accommodating can
we create software urban systems or are
we going to challenge nature
continuously with heavy infrastructure
which we are already doing unsuccessful
now I'm not arguing that we've got to
make our cities like a circus I'm not
arguing that cities must be completely
temporary I'm only making a plea that we
need to make a shift in our imagination
about cities where we need to reserve
more space for uses on a temporal scale
where we need to use our resources
efficiently to extend the expiry date of
our planet we need to change planning
urban design cultures to think of the
temporal the reversible the disassembled
and that can be tremendous in terms of
the effect it might have on our lives I
often think back to the Camilla that I
visited with my students and I studied
and this was a moment where the city had
been disassembled a week after the
festival is over there was no mark the
terrain was waiting to be covered over
by the water to be consumed and I I went
to thank a high priestess who had helped
us and my students through our research
and facilitated us through this process
and I went to her with great enthusiasm
and I told her about how much we had
learned about infrastructure the city
the efficiency of the city the
architecture the five materials that
made the city she looked really amused
she was smiling in any case she leant
forward and put her hand on my head to
bless me and she whispered in my ear she
said feel blessed that the mother Ganges
allowed you all to sit in her lap for a
few days I've often sort of thought
about this and of course I understood
what she said she said cities people
architecture will come and go but the
planet is here to stay
touch it lightly leave a minimal mark
and I think that's an important lesson
for us as citizens and architects and I
think it was this experience that made
me believe that impermanence is bigger
than permanence and bigger than us all
thank you for listening
[Applause]
[Music]